This is a serious crime against the
deity. It is a blasphemy beyond
blasphemies.
>> Vicarius fil we have found dozens
[music] of manuscripts where the name is
used. The classic Protestant perspective
was that the papacy was the antichrist.
>> Protestantism has totally capitulated.
>> He is exalting himself to be like the
[music] most high to sit in the throne
of God. Who is your sanctifier? Is
[music] it man who sanctifies himself or
is it Christ who sanctifies you? Well, I
prefer to [music] accept the moral
essence of the this book.
>> But you guys just mentioned earlier
about how similar we have the period now
to 1888.
>> Have the three angels message. This has
been our message to the world. Two out
of the three are warning about a false
system of worship and warning about
receiving a mark.
>> It's interesting where the dialogue is
going in public thought, suggesting
perhaps that death penalties could
[music] arise if you violate these laws.
God tells us what the moral essence is
and he says that [music] we should
remember the Sabbath day and not forget
it.
Heat. Heat.
[music]
Welcome back to Heritage and Hope
Ministries. Today I'm excited to be
joined by my brother James as always and
also Walter Vice and Martin Smith from
Clash of Minds. Guys, thank you so much
for joining us today.
>> It's a pleasure.
>> Thank you. It's an honor. Yeah. You
know, there's been a lot of conversation
uh over the years about the man of sin
and what is spoken of in Revelation uh
about that man of sin. But you know,
there's actually a verse before
Revelation in the New Testament that
talks about this person who exalts
himself over what is called God. What
What do we find there that is of
interest to us as historicist
Protestants?
Well, there's a lot in that verse that
has caused a lot of controversy over the
ages.
There are people of course who want to
throw this into the future. But if you
go back to historic Protestantism and
you take uh like Romanism and the
reformation written by Gratan Guinness
in the late 1800s,
uh it is obvious that the reformers had
a very distinct view on who this
personage was and they claimed it was
the papacy
who would be sitting in the temple of
God
assuming to He God. Now the temple of
God is a reference to the church because
Paul in many places says ye are the
temple of the living God in Ephesians
for example.
So the temple of God that he's referring
to here is not a temple of stone but a
temple
of human beings comprising the spiritual
Israel of God. And within this Christian
millure, there would be this man of sin
who would exalt himself above all that
is called God and that is worshiped. So
that he sits in this church setup
pretending or showing himself that he is
God. That is how the reformers
interpreted it. And historically there's
no other way in which it can be
interpreted
because Paul distinctly also says that
before the Lord can come there must
first be a falling away. And the man of
sin, the son of pition
must be exposed.
And that falling away would come when he
that opposes is taken out of the way.
And we have to go to the early church
fathers to see what that is referring
to. And they all are of one accord that
the reference there is to pagan Rome
that has to be removed to make way for
the rise of papal Rome. And then
eventually this papal power with its
seat and authority vested in in the
pontipical chair would take this
authority upon themselves within the
church of God supposedly
pretending that they are God and that
they can legislate above God. So
basically that was the interpretation of
the reformers and that is the
interpretation that is 100% in line with
historic
uh facts.
>> You know pastor Va there's a lot of uh
points you made there. One of the things
that we've been finding here in our our
studies here at Heritage and Hope is
when we look at the Latin in 2
Thessalonians 2:4 when it says that he
will show himself that he is God.
uh sequat
what's interesting is within canon law
itself the word ostendens or to show is
actually used in distinctio 96 satis
evident of the decretum gratiani now
this was we actually have a copy of
canon law right here Alex this one's
from 1559
and it says it is quite clearly shown
ostenditor the same Latin word ostendens
that the pontiff cannot not be bound by
the secular power which is evidently
called a god by the pious prince
Constantine since it is evident that
even a god cannot be judged by men uh
using specifically the word deum here
you know uh we find these actually in
multiple manuscripts throughout the
Vatican in the past few years they've
been digitizing them and they took it so
far in distinctio 40 that they said if
the pope fails and neglects fraternal
salvation if he's found useless and
remiss in his works and moreover silent
from good, which offends him more,
nevertheless leads countless peoples
with him as the first slave of hell,
with himself to be scourged with many
plagues for eternity. No mortal may
presume to rebuke the sins of this man
because he himself is to judge all.
Now, Alex, we've got some other
documents right here. I think this is
one of them right here from our Jesuit
series, the Sacraanka Consilia where the
Archbishop of Kfu Christopher Marcellis
uh at the fifth Lateran Council session
4 spoke of the pope as thou art finally
another God on earth
or we can see here Pope Leo I 13th we
hold upon this earth the place of God
almighty
and of course we've got this work right
here from 1766 this is Lucius Ferrer's
work that's often referenced uh as to
papal authority. The pope as it were God
on earth, sole sovereign of all the
faithful of Christ, chief king of kings,
having a plentitude of unbroken power uh
entrusted by the omnipotent God to
govern earthly and heavenly kingdoms.
Now it goes on to say that the pope is
of so great dignity and exalted as as he
were not mere man but as it were God and
the vicor of God. The pope alone is
called most holy. Hence the pope is
crowned with a triple crown of king of
heaven and of earth and of hell.
>> You know, you touch on these books.
That's why we're actually trying to get
these is to try and expose this system
that has been around for so long. You
know, the classic Protestant perspective
for hundreds of years was that the
papacy was the antichrist. And there's
actually a list online that is compiled
of all the different uh Protestants out
there who believed the pope was the
antichrist. And so rather than trying to
accept anyone's opinion on it, you know,
that's why we're actually collecting
these original works right here from the
Protestant Reformation um to try and
show people because these works, they're
not faximiles, they're not
reproductions. These are the real
original documents basically that show
that the antichrist did have these
claims. And it backs up the claims in
the book the great controversy which uh
you know talks about some of these
statements and I believe there's
actually mention in this book about uh
some statements in regards to that. Is
that right?
>> Yeah. So one of the statements in the
great controversy is uh that the pope
has been styled lord god the pope and
you know this has been something that uh
has been doubted over the years in some
cases. They some people have said it was
a later 16th century uh statement that
actually kind of crept in in error and
that the word dem wasn't in the original
manuscript that it was uh it was just an
interpolation but one of the things that
we've been finding here lately is prior
to the 16th century even in the 15th
century we see that it was very much
included in extravagantes of John the
22nd and of course it was consistent
with the main body of canon law where
the pope was shown as well. So it's some
people say it's a gloss but it was
actually consistent with the main body.
But even 400 years ago there was a
Jesuit Andreas Ude who spoke about the
original Zenzelini CEX or the gloss of
Zenzelini for extravagantes and said
that the word deum wasn't there. Said
that it just said Lord Lord the pope but
didn't say Lord God the Pope. And so,
uh, some people have commented that this
manuscript was carefully concealed from
the prying eyes of Protestants. But you
know what? It's no longer concealed.
It's been brought to light. Here is the
original 14th century vat. 13397. And
here is folio 166V upper left, six line
down from the top. Dominum, Deam,
Nostrom, Papamum. It actually was there.
Ellen White was right. all along and
later on in the uh the corrected edition
later on published by the pope. We can
see that it was actually included even
after the correct went through and made
corrections to extravagantes and the
main body of canon law. And there was
actually a Portuguese priest, Parra, who
we have his book right here, who said
that the popes have never disapproved or
rejected this title.
Why would they? I mean, it was
consistent with the main body of canon
law. But a question that I have is um
Pastor Vice, you know, in in 2
Thessalonians 2:4, we see this reference
to the man of sin. How does that connect
with Revelation, though?
>> Well, it connects absolutely. But uh
before I get there, I just want to say
that this is the beauty of your ministry
because as you correctly stated,
a lot of these documents have been
twisted, denied,
disappeared from the public eye ever
since the focus was on the papacy as the
antichrist.
And some of the artifacts have gone
awall and have been denied. But uh it is
amazing to me how many pens climb onto
that bandwagon and say these things
never existed. But in actual fact the
they are real and you have created a
library of proof to this effect so that
nobody can really deny it any longer.
Now the when the Bible talks
>> I just before you go into the Bible
study of it even in your total onslaught
series a lot of the references that's
put on there is not available anymore.
>> No.
>> So this that you are doing is just
really amazing in putting that together
that nobody can deny that it's been in
the originals.
>> Yes. It's not our purpose to hammer
anyone or any religious uh body. But the
fact of the matter is that this
organization has usurped the
prerogatives of Christ. They have
basically stolen them from the one to
whom they belong and applied them to
themselves.
This is a serious crime against the
deity.
And uh the Bible actually mentions that
and calls it the son of pedition.
Uh a title that only applies to the man
of sin and to Judas. It's a it's a
betrayal of the trust that has been
handed over to the church of the worst
possible kind. And the poor people that
are trapped in the system and are being
kept ignorant from the word of God and
most of these documents have no idea of
what actually transpires behind the
scene. So it's absolutely necessary that
the work that the reformation started
which has been buried under the sands of
time and uh not only buried um by
accident but on purpose that that should
be exposed again. Now the Bible is
replete with this information about this
antichrist power and it gives it various
names. In Daniel, it is called the
little horn power or the little horn
actually is not a little horn. It's one
that grew from littleness
uh into a mighty horn that became more
stout than the others and became
prescriptive.
Uh so there you have the little horn
power. Then uh if you carry on in
Daniel, it uh it refers to this power in
numerous places in Daniel 11 and about
its exalting himself etc etc. And you
pick it up in Revelation 11 where the
groundwork is laid for this deceptive
power, this beast out of the bottomless
pit that uh rules the world through a
woman. In Revelation chapter 17, it
tells us that this woman sits upon this
beast and actually controls its
movements. And the beast of course
referring to the political systems.
And in Revelation 13, you have a
conglomerate beast of Daniel chapter 7
with the attributes of the little horn
that he would persecute the saints, that
he would change times and laws, that he
would rule for a specific time period,
etc. So all of these align with the same
power. So Daniel speaks about it. Paul
gives a an overall view of the
characteristics of this power. How it
exalts itself, how it puts itself in the
place of God, how it actually has
manipulated its position within the
Christian uh church calling itself a
Christian power when actual fact it's
it's paganism dressed up as
Christianity.
And in the conglomerate beast of
Revelation chapter 13, you have all of
these attributes again. And then you
have a second power that will on behalf
of this first power that ruled during
the middle ages and changed times and
laws will again bring it to prominence,
enact its laws and thereby force the
world basically to worship this power
unbeknown to themselves unless someone
exposes it. And this is exactly what you
are doing with your documents and this
is what we are discussing right here
today. So the line you can draw it
absolutely clearly through through the
prophecies of Daniel
through the exposition thereof in the
reformation
eventually the events portrayed in in
chap in the chapters of revelation. It
is a crystal clear picture of where this
power is, how it rules or what its aims
are and what the consequences will be of
enforcing those aims.
>> You know, one of the things you
mentioned uh um about kind of documents
coming to light. I remember some years
ago I had read on one of the websites
that you guys had about a quote from the
Catholic National where there was a
cardinal before he became pope who said
that the pope is not merely the
representative of Jesus Christ but he is
Jesus Christ veiled under the flesh.
>> Yes, he's in the flesh.
>> And it was quoted from the Catholic
National. But over the years I know some
Catholic websites have denied and said
there's no such magazine. Well, uh we
actually reached out to Switzerland
actually to the burn uh university
library and found the Catholic national
which contains it was a Catholic
newspaper but it contains that
particular quote where the pope uh or
the cardinal cardinal actually we
believe was Cardinal Sto November 25th
1894 who made this statement actually
before he became pope. So, what they
said did not exist in the Catholic
National saying it's not a real
newspaper and kind of casting shade on
some of the quotes provided on your
websites. We've actually located and
found that no, they were actually
correct and the magazine existed and
there it is for for um for all to see.
July 13, 1895.
>> Now, Revelation 13 also speaks about the
man of sin. Uh, it also speaks about a
name though and a number associated with
that name, 666. And there's been a lot
of controversy about this over the years
as to what that equals or what that's
referring to. I've seen all sorts of
references, everything from tattoos,
barcodes to uh I think there's even
discussion these days about AI and all
kinds of other things that people are
are imagining. But one of the things
that we found in our research is there
was an old idea put forward in 1612 by
Andreas Halvig in his anti Christos
Romanus and it was interesting that he
went through even a cardinal Cardinal
Bellerin who was a Jesuit all of his
criteria as to because Bellerin was kind
of studying it as well and there was
some criteria that it whatever the
number was it must yield the required
number.
uh it must agree with the papal order.
It must be a not be a vile name applied
by enemies but but be acceptable to
antichrist himself. And it must be one
of which he can boast. And of all the
titles that the papacy used, Vicarius
Fade was the one that he landed on. And
it was very actually there's a lot of
evidence to support it. We've been doing
some research recently and um actually
for for those of you watching who aren't
familiar with how it adds up, here's the
gymria right here. But we've been doing
some research on the Vatican digital
library with new manuscripts digitized
within just the past few years and we
have found dozens of manuscripts.
There's the folios uh or pageionation
for each of the places where the name is
used. But in many cases it uh it's
actually used in canon law. Uh we've
actually got it in this book right here
in Distinctio 96 as well. Constantinous
emperator is the chapter. It's also in
Lucius Ferah's book here as well. But um
it was interesting that it was included
in a phrase where it was constituted
which means to establish by force of
law. And pastor V I'm sure you've seen
some references over the years to it
being on a on a tiara. Have you read
anything about that before? Yes, there
were a number of witnesses that claimed
that they had seen uh this tiara,
actually independent witnesses, not in
collusion.
And then the tiara disappeared from
public display and it was denied that
this tiara ever existed.
Then there were people in Protestant
ranks and sadly even in our own ranks
that started vehemently denying that
this uh interpretation of Vicario's file
day was actually correct. But then the
reference to it was also made in our
Sunday visitor if I remember correctly
which was a a document which was brought
out by the Roman Catholic Church and
then if they had made a mistake on that
why did they republish it a few years
later with the exact same information
but since then many documents and I'm
sure that you've has given a tremendous
list have substantiated this so that
even the greatest skeptic even within
our own midst must admit that they they
were wrong. But this this name has an
interesting history because you can you
can take it back a lot further than uh
the papacy not the name itself but the
number 666 and what it is associated
with. And uh perhaps I can just I don't
want to talk all the time but uh perhaps
just run through this briefly.
Uh the man of sin is a representative of
Satan
and Revelation makes it quite clear that
the dragon gives him his seat and his
great authority.
Now this word seat is a very important
word
because we also talk about the papal
seat the one from which he speaks with
authority excided
infallibly.
Now this seat originally of course
belonged to the devil and uh Satan had
this seat and if you go through the book
of revelation you will find that
peragamum
is mentioned there that is the time
period of religious compromise when
Constantine
uh supposedly converted to Christianity
although he was a methraic he was the
sun worshipper at the same time.
And it tells us quite clearly in the
book of revelation that Pergamum is the
place where Satan has his seat.
Now this this town or this city Pergamum
is an interesting one because that is
the place where the Babylonian
priesthood established itself after the
Meo Persians conquered Babylon.
And they retained uh this uh city even
through the Meoersian time period and
the Greek time period and eventually
relinquished their title
uh to the Roman emperor. And uh this
title was pontifffect maximus
which was the supreme pontiff
and he is where revelation tells us is
seated where satan has his seat. Now
that seat then moved when he
relinquished the last king I think who
did that was Atalus III when he
relinquished his title then gave it to
the Caesars
uh he had to also take this title of
deity with it. So this is very important
that he it was attached to deity. So the
pontiff there the pontifffect maximus
was also a god.
Now the early Roman emperors didn't
apply this deity to themselves
but after Julius Caesar took the title
and applied it to himself then all the
emperors subsequent to Julius Caesar
also took that title of deity and this
is where emperor worship came in and uh
it was enforced by law and of course the
early Christians were martyed as a
consequence because they couldn't bow
down to a pagan god king with that
title. Now, where does that title sit
today? It sits with Rome because Rome
took the title Pontifax Maximus.
Therefore, in Revelation chapter 13, it
says that Satan or the dragon gave him
his seat and his power and great
authority. So that seat has moved from
Babylon
to Pergamum to the Caesars and then to
the papal Caesars if we can call them
that and they have the title and they
have the deity.
So if this is a continuity that you have
and a shift merely in position rather
than in authority
then that title sits today with Rome and
they're very proud of it because it's
behind every name PM pontifacts maximus.
Well, you even I was just thinking
earlier when we were discussing the
original documents and the books that
you have a lot of people also claim that
yes okay but that was what they said
then they don't state it now
but if there's quite a few places where
you can go and search about it and I
think we can talk about that also but as
a very um clear one is if you go to the
Twitter account or now exac account of
the pope
It's act pontifix.
>> Yes.
>> So it's still right there in your face.
>> It's right there in your face. They
cannot deny it. And they couldn't deny
it without violating their own doctrine
because papal infallibility requires
that they cannot change their doctrine.
It's like a law of Mes and Persians. You
cannot change it because it would
violate the very principle on which the
papacy is based.
It's interesting that uh you know it the
number 666 we find in some of the pagan
symbols out there very much associated
with sun worship. You can see that here
on the Sajia Solus at the Museum of
Berlin.
>> I recently found a one of those kind of
emulets uh that sold on stacks and
bowers. Here it is right here in the
gold. And it actually sold for $6,600.
>> But um on the monstrance right here you
can see sigma d gamma stigma. So 666
reflected on this particular monstrance.
>> But uh one of the things too about the
tiara is even though not all of the
tiaras are photographed and we don't
have photographic evidence of of that we
do have the this one right here which is
uh was a gift of the ladies of the royal
court of king Leopold 2 of Belgium
presented to the pope in 1871. It was
designed by Jean Baptiste Bthun of Gent
in a neo gothic style and it has a Latin
inscription reignum at popularum hatri
orb supremo intera
infallibility but what you can see right
here is christi vicarius in terra one of
the things that's important about that
is our Sunday visitor admits that that
is a uh the same thing as ficarius
christi right here uh in vicarious fil
in other words they're analogous but one
of the things that I find is if you look
biblically at Leviticus 24:18 he that
kleth a beast shall make it good beast
for beast the substitute is vicarium but
when it says beast for beast the word
anti is used in the substitutionary
sense so in the Latin vicarius christi
is analogous in the Greek to anticristos
erggo what this is really saying right
here is antichrist right on the front of
this tiara.
>> Now as far as vicarious fil goes there
was actually a forged document the
donation of constantine which included
this particular phrase from the
pseudoidorian decorals vicarious fil
unfortunately although the donation of
constantine this phrase came from a
forge document and it found its way into
the body of right here. Yeah.
>> Yeah. when it was actually discovered by
Lorentius Valla, one of the things that
he went back and did was he exposed all
of this as hey you know this donation of
Constantine is forged. Now Rome didn't
want that being exposed and so they put
Lorentius Valla's work exposing the
donation of Constantine as a forgery on
the index liorum prohibitorum following
the council of Trent. They didn't want
the whistle being blown that they were
relying upon forged documents. What we
do find right here though is is that the
the phrase from canon law actually found
its way into documents like
interapacibus
the blessed Peter is is seen to have
been constituted which means to
establish by force of law vicarious
filid so to the pontiffs who having been
granted by us in our empire or this one
right here one once again more of the
decret gratanus which found its way into
the main corpus of of canon law and you
can see this reflected in multiple
copies is available on the Vatican
digital library to this day. Now,
distinction 19 also had a statement
within these decrees where among
canonical scriptures the decorative
epistles are co-enumerated. So, in other
words, this was on level with canonical
scripture. So it was very much
authoritative and the whole appeal to
whether or not it's on a tiara is kind
of a bit of a red herring because the
real authority from this comes from law
from apostolic constitutions papal
decrees from the main uh documents that
are coming out of the magisterium and
you can see an example of that here the
corpus Iris Kenanichi this one uh this
particular edition was put forward in uh
1587 seven for this one right here and
it has Pope Gregory I 13th's
introduction to it again where the pope
is constituted vicarious fili dei we can
also see this in cardinal Juan
decommatada's suma decli so uh there's
another copy right here another
statement included in John the 22nd's
let yuksta doctrina now John the 22nd in
his time there was a work put forward by
Austinus triumphus It was put forward to
kind of defend papal supremacy, papal
authority. And it it said right here
that the Christian emperor Constantine
testified saying the blessed Peter is
seen to have been constituted vicarious
fili.
What I find interesting and uh oh well
sorry this is this is Pope John the 22nd
Let Yuksta doctrina. This is his
apostolic constitution right here. Um
we're going to move on though to the
Augustina's triumph work right here. and
Augustina's triumph suma de potista.
This particular copy was was had Gregory
the 13th's seal on it. The same one who
celebrated St. Bartholomew's massacre.
But in the same document uh das sabati
indium Dominican apa mutata s. So the
sabbath to Sunday was changed by the
pope.
>> There it is.
>> Yep. So in the same document putting
forth papal authority as kind of a very
high watermark we see this reference to
his authority as well in changing the
Sabbath to Sunday that was went side by
side vicarious filid and its usage. So
it's interesting how they were
interconnected.
Now you can find vicarious filides still
on the papal website or the Vatican
website to this day in the apostolic
constitution
uh right here from Rivy Munencis in 1965
Pope Paul the 6 also Bafen 1968 as well
it's reflected throughout we also have
it in this work as I mentioned before
and I've got a copy of that in a slide
right here Alex is there a lot of
evidence
>> you know there's there's an awful lot of
evidence I you know I think though that
there has to be a lot of evidence. You
know I think about how did what was
Lucifer's original uh main issue. His uh
one of his main issues was that he had
pride in his heart. You think about
Isaiah 14:12. How art thou fallen from
heaven, oh Lucifer, son of the morning?
How art thou cut down to the ground
which did weaken the nations? For thou
hast said in thine heart, I will ascend
into heaven. I will exalt my throne
above the stars of God. I will sit upon
the mount of the congregation in the
sides of the north. I will ascend above
the heights of the clouds. I will be
like the most high. If we look at this
antichrist power, this beast power, this
little horn power that we see mentioned,
you know, throughout scripture, one of
the main things is if it's going to
mimic Satan and if it's basically going
to be Satan's mouthpiece, it must then
by necessity be prideful and boastful.
And so this 666 power, it's not going to
be something that's like secretive that
you have to like go and secretly reveal.
No, it's going to be out in the open
that is pushed forward to all. You're
going to see it inscribed right on the
front. You know, um you guys were just
talking about that Pontifffects Maximus
title. You see it uh and you took the
words out of my mouth, Martin, when you
said it's the Twitter handle because
yeah, it's right there for all to see.
But you go on all the Vatican coins.
Pontifffects Maximus is on the Vatican
coins. Uh you see it inscribed on the
actual underneath uh the the main church
there in the Vatican. Um uh and you can
see it inscribed in stone right there.
Uh where you see that. So this is not,
you know, a system where they're trying
to keep it hidden. Um there's actually
images of the pope where he has cherubam
on either side of him as he's as he's
seated there. So you see this imagery
where he is exalting himself to be like
the most high to sit in the throne of
God. And so this title this papal title
vicarious fili basically the substitute
of Christ
it's very blasphemous right because no
nobody can truly be a substitute for
Christ but at the same time it's
expected. Uh, and I believe and I've
I've heard you discuss this before where
there was actually a student who went
and looked and said, "Okay, let's
identify all the different examples." I
believe he was Catholic and he he said,
"Okay, let's let's look at this title
666. What title would fit the bill and
it has to be one that the uh antichrist
comes up with on his own?"
>> Yeah. So, so Andreas Helvik uh
>> Yeah. So, what was the criteria there
for that?
>> So, yeah. Andreas Helvig being a
Protestant uh actually came up with uh w
with that recognition of the title
originally and this this wasn't even an
Adventist idea.
>> No,
>> I mean this came long before 7th day
Adventist. But one of the things that
you talked about is the papal pride and
pretension.
>> You know in Daniel 7, this power thinks
so much of itself that it can modify or
change divine times and laws.
>> Right? And that's a critical point right
there because in these manuscripts
one of the things that we find for
example in the decretles or decrees of
Gregory the 9th uh is according to the
fullness of power we can dispense above
the law. Now in 2 Thessalonians 2:4 the
Latin vulgate is supra for above. And
here we find once again supra where the
pope is is above the law. And it goes on
and to say that for not man but God
separates those whom the Roman pontiff
who exercises the functions not of a
mere man but of the true God having wed
the necessity or benefit of the churches
dissolves not by human but rather by
divine authority. I mean, these are
available on the Vatican website to this
day. And it says right here, the Pope is
said to have a heavenly power of
determination and therefore changes the
nature of things and that his will
stands for law and that he can set free
from the obligation of the law and that
he can make just that which is unjust by
correcting and changing laws. It's
interesting the word for changing there,
mutando, to mutate. right
>> now. Um I believe that uh in in uh your
previous discussions, uh Walter, um
there's been some discussion about how
this papal power has been so prideful
and put itself forward as being this
this boastful power. Um, and so Walter
and Martin, what what were some examples
that you guys have seen in addition that
kind of show I mean, yeah, there's the
picture of him sitting between
cherubims, but what other evidences do
we have of this prideful position of the
papacy? Because some people would try
and deny that to this day and say, "Oh,
no, the Pope is humble." And you know,
Pope Francis and Pope Leo have both
actually tried to present this more
humble appearance. You actually don't
see them wearing the same triregnums
that the previous popes wore where it
was this multi-tiered elaborate gold,
you know, diamond encrusted uh tiara.
Instead, they're wearing something more
simple. And I think it's to show a form
of piety. But h what other uh evidences
do we have of this prideful, boastful
power?
>> Well, if you just take the doctrine of
infallibility, it must be one of the
most prideful doctrines that have ever
seen the light.
uh if you imagine what they are actually
saying and then going beyond that and
saying that they can change even the
precepts of Christ that elevates
themselves above Christ [snorts] and
above uh heaven. That's why he calls
himself uh a king with a triple triara
uh which represents the heaven, the
earth and the nether world. So he rules
not only about over this earth, he rules
over heaven. Now if you want to rule
over heaven, then you must be higher
than Christ.
Uh you're going to be more boastful than
that and that the pope's will stand for
reason and that he can dispense above
the law by correcting and changing law
and of making right that which is wrong
and wrong that which is right. The
Jesuits go so far as to say if the
general says that something is black and
you know that it's white, then you have
to become like a corpse and accept that
his rendition is correct and yours is
incorrect. You have to change.
Those are exceedingly
arrogant statements.
Now the I think the listeners need to
understand where this system and this
number actually comes from. Well, it
comes from Babylon, but it's originated
in Satan. Now, Satan's Greek title is
Titan.
Uh, Ti Tan,
and the numerical value of that, if you
take the numerical value of the letters
is 666.
So, Satan's number is 666.
But Satan rules through proxies.
So he is like the god Anu that gives his
power to Marduk
to rule here on earth. And therefore
these god kings they were the ones that
uh expressed this power or utilized this
power given to them. And if you take the
papal titles for example, then it's
quite uh quite informative.
So if you take the Latin Basilea, which
means the Latin kingdom, they called
themselves Helatina Basilea, that works
out to 666.
If you take Italia ecclesia, which is
the the Latin church, that works out to
666.
or the official time title Latinos or
the Latin speaking man referring to the
papacy that works out to 666 and of
course Vicario FE
exactly the same. So the title
originally belongs to the master of them
all which is Lucifer who gives it to his
proxies. If you take the the Babylonian
amulets, they were based on sun worship
and zodiac worship. And the zodiac
divide was divided into 12 regions. Each
one with three rooms.
That makes a number of 36 rooms. And
each of these rooms had a deity. And
above that was another deity. And
eventually all of it was under the sun
god. And eventually Mitraa or Mitra
became the most popular form of that sun
god. And if you add those numbers up, so
if you add the numbers 1 to 36, so 1 + 2
+ 3 + 4 + 5 etc. all the way to 36, that
comes to 3, that comes to 666.
So it's a pagan religion where sun
worship takes the place and the sun
deity takes the place of the true God.
So the early art uh emphasizes this. If
you take the pictures that the papacy
portrays of Jesus, those are basically
pagan pictures with a sun flare and
blaze behind his head uh depicting the
sun god. And mitraism
uh then became the main religion
basically in the late periods of the
pagan Roman power.
And uh the day that was assigned to
Midra was de Solus, the day of the sun,
which originally in the Roman calendar
was the second day of the week. But
because of the prominence of Mitra, they
elevated it to the first day of the
week. Now this is fascinating because if
you go to Revelation chapter 13
then the feet that this conglomerate
beast stands on is the feet of a bear
and the bear is mitraism.
So what is what is this foundation that
he is standing on? Well, it's sun
worship. It's Mitraism
and the day was de solace the day of the
sun and the papacy very early in its
inception
accepted this day of the sun when the
Sabbath was outlawed by the emperor
Hadre and incorporated it as the day of
the resurrection without one word of
biblical authority. So there's a there's
a very fascinating line through paganism
to Christianized paganism. And if
anybody wants to doubt that Christianity
in the papal system is nothing other
than Christianized paganism,
you can just take all their doctrines
which are from pagan origin. Take the
doctrine of purgatory. Take the doctrine
of infant baptism.
uh take the doctrine of uh eating a
consecrated host that was part of the
Mithraic uh ritual. This is Mitraism.
It's sun worship in its absolute form.
>> Well, just on those three that you've
just mentioned, you asked earlier, what
else are they still doing that's
blasphemous? Basically,
>> those all of that is still blasphemous
and they're still doing it. Not not only
is it blasphants
on board to partake in this apostasy
with them. So a unified communion or
eukarist is one of the aims of the
papacy.
Uh
>> the the jubilee is a jubilee year now.
>> Yes.
>> And that's giving indulgences.
That is that is another arrogance that
uh God has to abide by the judgment of
his priests and uh basically
submit himself to whatever the judgment
of the priest is and that priestly power
emanates from the papacy. The pope is
the one who delegates this power to the
priesthood to to say that the the priest
is an altar Christos another Christ who
can dispense with sins and forgive sins.
Uh the Roman documents say there is one
man or one person on this earth who can
forgive sins and that is the Roman
priesthood or the Roman priest. That is
a blasphemy because the Bible says, "Who
can forgive sins but God alone?" So all
of these statements, none of them have
been retracted. They cannot retract them
because of their infallibility.
And that Protestantism
should be buying into this paganized
Christianity. I mean, we're in December
now. We're going for for Christmas. The
25th of December was the birth date of
Mitra. Nowhere in the Bible do we read
anything of that nature. Or what about
Easter?
Easter is is a pagan is a pagan feast
that was uh well it's a basically a a
sex ritual. That's why they have the
Easter bunny because it is a great
propagator of offspring. And you have
the hen with her eggs, the Easter egg,
because she has a great number of of
offspring in her clutch. So these are
all um rituals that have been
incorporated into Christianity.
And then they moved Easter because he
changed times so that it'll always fall
on a Sunday.
Whereas um the Jews kept it according to
the levitical system which was
determined by the full moon and
therefore it could fall on any day of
the week but the papacy decreed that it
would always have to be a Sunday. And
very interesting if by chance they
happen to coincide so that the full moon
does fall on a Sunday then the papacy
will move Easter by one week. And that
is exactly what John Paul II did. I
think it was in 2001
where he moved Easter with a by a week
because uh it coincided with uh the
Jewish p and they didn't want that
because it is a it is a pagan festival
uh foisted or hoisted onto onto
Christianity. All of it is pagan and
they're proud of it. They're not hiding
it. They're putting it in plain sight.
>> One of the things that's interesting is
uh the when we're speaking about the
Pope elevating himself, we read right
here in the Catechism for the Council of
Trent for parish priests, the bishops
and priests being as they are God's
interpreters and ambassadors empowered
in his name to teach mankind the divine
law and the rules of conduct holding as
they do his place on earth. It is
evident that nobler function can theirs
can be imagined. justly. Therefore, they
are called not only angels but even gods
because of the fact that they exercise
in our midst the power and prerogatives
of the immortal God. Now, within that
system,
there is a power or within the papacy
actually of being above all of the rests
of the bishops and priests in a sense
universal. And so, by elevating himself,
he makes himself god of gods, if you
will. uh we find this actually reflected
speaking to the universal nature with
this bishop in vat.lat.1321 lat 1321.
This contains from Gregory IIIth the
dictatus pepe where right here in the
Latin uh it says right here quot solos
romanus pontfex y uric universalis or
the Roman pontiff alone can be with
right called universal. So he sets
himself above all of the other bishops
in that sense and in so doing changing
the law of God. And you know one of the
things that I think we're trying to tell
the world is in Revelation 14 there is a
group of people who keep the
commandments of God who escape these
four violations of God's law
specifically worship of the beast. Uh an
image to the beast corresponding to
commandments one and two. uh the name of
the beast, commandment three, and
finally the mark of the beast in
commandment four. Well, what I find
interesting is that these individuals
who escape having his father's name
written in their foreheads. Now, what is
his father's name? Well, you know, in
Amos 9:6, we read, "The Lord is his
name." And Ezekiel 20, we find right
here once again this name being
connected in Ezekiel 20:12. Moreover, I
also gave them my Sabbath to be a sign
between me and them that they might know
that I am the Lord
that sanctify them. So, it's a symbol,
an outward sign of who is your
sanctifier. Is it man who sanctifies
himself or is it Christ who sanctifies
you? And this really speaks to the very
heart of salvation process where it is
the work of God upon the heart who
sanctifies you and the Sabbath itself is
directly connected to that. Uh it's kind
of central to Protestantism and escaping
this power that thinks that man can
change the law of God. You know, I think
about um Ezekiel where it talks about uh
in chapter 9 verse 2, there's a mention
of uh this destruction that goes forth
with a you know, there's this man that
goes forth with a slaughtering weapon in
his hand. And if you read through this
chapter, there's discussion of a mark in
the forehead that saves. It says um in
Ezekiel 9:6, "Lay utterly old and young,
both maidens and little children and
women, but come not near any man upon
whom is the mark, and begin at my
sanctuary." So there's this idea in
scripture of this mark in the forehead
that saves. Exodus 31:13, "Speak thou
also unto the children of Israel,
saying, verily my Sabbath you shall
keep, for it is a sign between me and
you throughout your generations, that ye
may know that I am the Lord that that
doth sanctify you." you know, um, Walter
and Martin, you were just kind of
discussing
how there's sun symbolism with the
papacy that's it's pagan that has crept
in. And James, where is it in scripture
that talks about the four abominations?
And what were those four abominations
spoken of? And what was the most
tremendous abomination
uh, for the Jews?
>> Well, it's actually a chapter right
before the one you just mentioned in
Ezekiel 8. There's all sorts of
abominable beasts. Uh we see Tamuz
worship. Tamuz being kind of setting up
a false name in in contrast to God's
name. Of course, there's images
referenced there as well. But the fourth
abomination and the highest of them all
is four, five, and 20 elders with their
backs to the temple bowing down to the
sun. It is the highest abomination of
all of those four abominations.
And it is directly before the test in uh
Ezekiel chapter 9 which is very very
similar to Revelation 14 where in this
case you have a life-saving sign upon
the forehead but in Revelation 14 you
can have this this mark on your hand or
on your forehead which condemns you. And
um one of the things that I was going to
mention too is, you know, it's hard to
miss all of this when you look at the
rest of Revelation about uh what this
power really is. You know, we've got how
this power is very much mentioned in
Revelation 17 as well where it's it's
this represented as this woman having a
golden cup. Of course, Rome's done that
as well. And even the word vaticanus
itself, vates in the Latin dictionary
referencing a prophet if you will or
diver or some kind of you know seer or
foreteller. And then anus meaning old
woman. Actually this was reflected in
Latin proverbs like anus subsotans
multimix excited pulveris or an old
woman dancing stirs up dust.
>> Basically [clears throat] anything out
of season was obnoxious. But uh but the
the word vaticananus if you connect it
together it's old woman of prophecy
>> and one of the things that we find right
here is even in St. John of Latin where
originally it was the home of the
pontiffs for about a thousand plus years
and right outside of this you can see an
inscription sacros latin ecclesium uh
erbiset orbis ecclesiarum m at kaput so
she's claiming to be the mother of
churches well I I go back to
constantine's edict um you know back in
March 7th of 321 on the venerable day of
the son
talking about uh bringing people
together that they may worship on that
day. And so right there when
Christianity was in its infancy just 300
years in you have this change to Sunday
uh where where he's having to make an
edict to tell people to worship on this
day of the sun uh which has interesting
connotations when you look at Rome and
how they used used to worship soul
invictus. It's interesting too that all
of this with Constantine around the year
321 you end up with just a few years
later in 325 with the council of Nika
there was a lot of stuff that was taking
place at that time period and
>> what did we just have happen actually
[laughter]
>> well we just saw after 1700 years
something huge with this mother church
kind of marshalling people underneath
her wings. Uh what were your guys'
thoughts on what's happened here
recently?
>> Well, I was fascinated to read about uh
the Pope visiting Turkey
and uh they he visited the mosque. He
wouldn't uh pray with the imam on this
particular occasion and he made some
excuse. But then he went to the
patriarch of the Orthodox Church
and it's fascinating to me that they
made quite a point of it in the in the
news
>> that they were praying towards the east
>> and that's exactly what you were talking
about there in the book of Ezekiel. Now
if you take this this this issue of the
east, it it has a very ancient origin.
When Adam and Eve were driven out of
Eden, they were driven out of the east
gate and so they left in the direction
of the east.
Early on they all worshiped towards the
west because they had to turn round and
face the garden of Eden which was now
barred for their entrance because the
cherub prevented them from entering. So
the worship was towards the west but
Cain he marched on towards the east and
directed his attention towards the east
which is the rising sun.
And in order for him to have some form
of authority
so that uh he would not be eliminated on
this earth, he received the mark of
Cain.
Now that mark of Cain was a mark of
authority to rule over the children of
of uh evil. Now, it's interesting that
the papacy claims that exact power that
they have the authority to rule over the
people of this earth and that nobody has
the right to judge them. They own all
property, which is something that God
also claims. They can alienate all
property and uh they can dispense above
the law and uh nobody has the right to
do it to them. So they can alienate
governments, they can get rid of kings,
they can do all of these things, but uh
nobody may do it to them. And the fact
of the matter is that their churches are
all built towards the east or most of
them at least. So that the worship is
towards the east. Something which the
book of Ezekiel highlights because it is
paganism. It is sun worship. And
therefore, it is only right in their
eyes at least that the day of the sun
should be the highlight of their worship
day. In other words, the the perpetual
Easter of their power. And they've
actually claimed that in their writings.
>> This power went so far previously that
those who didn't go along with her, you
couldn't buy or sell. Yeah, that's what
I just wanted to just briefly mention
that we're probably going to get to that
if we read in Revelation 13 verse 16 to
18.
But before I mention that, just I I
remembered now when you showed that
documents that's still on the Vatican's
website of um 1968 and 1965,
I think that's after Vatican 2 that it's
already telling you that there's no
change.
M that was just something I thought
about and then to come back to this
>> that's a great point. Yeah.
>> Maybe you're going to um discuss it also
now but when we read from verse 16 and
he causes all all both small and great
rich and poor free and bond to receive a
mark in their right hand or in their
foreheads and that no man man might buy
or sell save he that had the mark or the
name of the beast or the number of his
name. And then it goes on to identify it
as the 666.
But can maybe you can just quickly
explain to us what does it mean to have
the number?
>> To have the number means that you have
submitted to the authority of that
number because uh Cain who received the
mark of Cain had the authority to punish
sevenfold anyone who opposed him. and uh
his later offspring increased that to 70
* 7.
And it's fascinating to me that Christ
says you must forgive 70* 7. Unless of
course you have new translations that
violate that and make it 77.
>> But that's of course a reference to
Daniel's chapter 8 and 9 where it refers
to uh the time of probation closing
after 70* 7. So you must forgive until
probation closes.
>> Mhm.
>> So who has this power to forgive or not
to forgive in in terms of the earthly
powers? Well, the papacy claims that
power. And if you subject to it, if you
subject yourself to it, then you are a
servant to him that you subject yourself
>> even if it's not worshiping. Even if
it's just by that's why it's either or.
Well, let's let's put it this way. If
you are commanded to do something which
is directly contrary to the explicit
will of God in the Bible and you choose
to go against the word of God and to run
along with the stream,
then you receive that that title or
>> the number
>> that number you have received it and you
received that name. Name is also a
reference to character and the character
of God is portrayed in the ten
commandments. So if you subject
yourselves to the character of the man
of sin and to his changed ten
commandments which by the way are an
abomination
then uh well then you are subject to
that power and if you place it at a
authority level higher than that of
Christ then you are actually worshiping
a counterfeit. So I think basically what
we're seeing is you're going to have two
marks at the end of time.
>> Yes.
>> You're going to have a ceiling mark like
what's spoken of in Ezekiel that is in
the forehead which means you understand
it's it's your reason. It's your thought
and you believe uh that that uh it is
true and this is the seal of God and uh
God's righteous people are going to be
sealed with this at the end of time. But
then you also have this mark of the
beast which is either in the hand or in
the forehead. Meaning that you can
either consent to it and actually
believe it in your in your mind or hand
signifying action. You may not believe
it but you'll go along with it.
>> Yes, you'll act accordingly.
>> How does that equate to uh James, you
had some stuff on on buying and selling
uh specifically. How does that equate to
buying and selling? Well, you know,
Revelation speaks of the power that was,
is not, and yet is. And we know that
this power lost uh civil authority in
1798 when it's when it's received a
deadly wound.
>> But for those who are looking at the end
of time when this power revives,
you know, we we need only understand and
look at the past, look at the history of
how this power has ruled to understand
the end time conclusions of of who
controls buying and selling. And one of
the some of the evidence for that is is
Pope Alexander III at the Council of
Tours and this is comes from the Vatican
digital library as well that they've
digitized in the past few years forbid
under an anathema that any should
presume to keep them in their houses or
on their land, sustain them or transact
any business with them. We can see here
as well that uh this was of course
reflected in the Jesuit works that we
have in our collection as well. But even
William the Conqueror made all the land
of the English tributory to the Roman
pontiff and did not allow anyone in his
power to buy or sell anything who was
found disobedient to the apostolic sea.
So you have the civil authority that
says, "Hey, we want to we want everybody
to follow God and as he defines it or as
he thinks and which really means
following the apostolic sea and
enforcing that through coercion that the
comforts of humanity having been lost,
they may be compelled to return from the
error of their way." So basically, the
devil's plot right here is to get you to
love the comforts of humanity more than
you love your savior. That's really what
it boils down to here. And the sad
reality is is that um what we've got got
going on with all the ecumenicism and
with the even in the Christian
nationalists crowd here in the United
States, there are those who are saying
now that we're okay with unregenerate
obedience. What they mean is is that if
you're coerced,
basically receiving the the mark in the
hand, you're you're forced through
action to do it, but you don't actually
believe it. You don't actually believe
it in your mind, but they're okay with
just forcing obedience, even if a person
doesn't really believe it because
uh they believe that doing so will bring
about a reformation in America and bring
back these religious values that they
really want to see, a revival. But it's
a revival through coercion. It's not a
revival through the power of the Holy
Spirit to change and convict men's
hearts. It is not even consistent with
the new covenant where God's law is
written on the heart, but very much
consistent with um the devil's strategy
from the very beginning. Even going back
to the days of Cain and Abel, it was
Abel's sacrifice that was accepted
before God. It was offered in faith. But
when Cain's sacrifice was rejected, he
rose up and slew his brother Abel. And
it's that that system of of killing
those who disagree has been reflected in
Satan's government throughout history
ever since.
>> You know, one of the things that um I
think is interesting is a lot of the
Christian nationalists today, they no
longer view the papacy as the Antichrist
power. And yet the symbolism is there in
spades. The paganism and we kind of
touched on this before and we've kind of
danced around this topic of sun worship.
And we've we've talked about, you know,
how um on the venerable day of the sun,
Constantine had this edict change. But
what what kind of symbolism do we see um
that the um Vatican still has sun
worship enscconced in its various
ceremonies and that type of thing? I
mean do we do we still see some symbols
of sun worship present that have held
over from the Roman paganism where they
used to worship Soul Invictus the god of
the sun. Um do we still see that today?
What would you say uh Walter and Martin?
Well, you just uh recently or just a few
moments ago spoke about Tamuz, right?
And the worship of Tamuz. And then you
read in in scripture that the women of
Zion were weeping over Tamuz.
Now Tamuz of course was the son of Baal
and Seami Ramis who used to be Baal used
to be Nimrod that ascended up into the
sun and became part of the sun and then
impregnated uh through a divine sun ray
seamis and she gave birth to this son
Tamuz
and they would bake cakes to him and
these cakes had the sign of Tamuz which
is basically an evensided cross and to
this very day in Easter times we
actually do have these hot cross buns so
nothing has really changed. Uh the whole
Easter ritual is based on paganism and
and is as far removed from the Christian
Passover as the east is from the west.
So you have all of this sun worship
imagery. Then you have of course uh the
goddess, the queen of heaven, Isis,
Ishta, whatever you want to call her.
And uh Roman Catholicism has exact same
thing. So they will portray Mary also
with a sun blaze behind her as uh
basically the the modernday embodiment
of Seiramis.
And the Bible clearly tells us that the
dead know nothing that they sleep. And
yet here all of these saints are defied.
Now in ancient times uh they believed
that uh when you died you actually went
and became a star
and the stars were clustered together in
constellations. And eventually uh
because they believed everything
revolved around the sun, the sun was the
the main deity. So you have all of these
so-called living stars who are really
mortals and are asleep according to the
scripture
and you have all of this in in
Catholicism and you have them as
mediators. So all that has happened is
that they've changed the names of the
particular deities but they haven't
changed the essence at all.
So paganism is alive and well and living
in Roman Catholicism and being swallowed
hookline and sinker by Protestantism.
>> And what about in the Eucharist?
Sometimes there's imagery where the pope
or the priest have that big solar
um emblem and then put the wafer inside
of that and walks behind it.
>> Yes. You had a picture of a monstrance
uh just a little while ago and the
monstrance of course has the sickle moon
at the bottom and that sickle moon
represents the womb of the woman into
which Tamuz the sun god was born. So
that is why they have a round wafer god.
Nowhere in scripture do you read about a
round wafer god that is then planted
within this womb into the sickle moon of
the monstrance. And then the monstrance
often has the straight and curvy uh
little rods attached to it. And the
curve curved ones stand for the female
and the the straight one for the male.
It's a form of uh phallic worship if you
would like.
And then this is carried around and
adored which is done to this very day in
the papal processions where they march
the host the consecrated hosts through
the streets for veneration. That's pure
pagan sun worship. Nowhere in the
scripture do you read anything like
that.
One of the things though that we're
seeing is in Revelation 14, we know that
there's a lot of paganism in Babylon.
But where is this going
in prophetic time? You know, and there's
a warning there about the mark of the
beast, which Protestants all the way
back since Thomas Tillum, Peter
Chamberlain, John Lavington, uh, many
other individuals have identified Sunday
with Rome's mark or or the mark of the
beast crisis. It's interesting where the
dialogue is going in public thought. One
of the things that I'm seeing here
recently is Twitter has now kind of
turned into the platform since Ellen
Musk obtained it of where a lot of this
dialogue is taking place specifically
calling for Sunday legislation
and some of the comments we're seeing
here recently from individuals detaining
Sabbath breakers, works of necessity. Uh
this individual responds indeed. or
another uh place from the reformed
Christian, a few things that are just
and righteous. Enforcing the Christian
Sabbath was civil penalties, laws
against blasphemy,
civily penalizing citizens who can
attend public worship and refuse.
One of this one of the blue checks here
responded, "What civil penalties for the
Sabbath? Would it involve killing anyone
who didn't keep it? That's what the
Mosaic law required." The reformed
Christian responded, "It depends on the
severity of the offense
[laughter] thereby suggesting perhaps
that death penalties could arise if you
violate these laws." We read other
individuals saying, "Sunday is the
Christian Sabbath and rescending the
blue laws allowed non-Christians to do
business on Sunday, selling alcohol and
such on the holy Christian Sabbath
Sunday." This had a profound effect on
the American Christian society. Here we
find someone else saying, "Bring back
Sabbath laws. Well-formed Sabbath laws
are social justice at its finest,
organizing uh civilizational time around
the sacrifice of praise due unto God."
You know, it's interesting to me seeing
the the parallels between 1888 and what
we're going through now. One of the
things that uh some individuals have
commented on is that in that time period
when our church faced, if you will,
Cesty is now we're here with maybe
Titus.
>> But
>> two non-consecutive presidential terms
with Grover Cleveland. Now we have a
president, the second one in American
history with two non-consecutive
presidential terms. We have Pope Leo I
13th in 1888. Now we have Pope Leo I
14th. We have the Blair Sunday Act. And
>> it depends on how things go in the
future. But to me, project 2025 and some
of the uh pushes there look very
similar, very similar.
>> It's interesting too that in uh at that
time period, there was a heavy influence
of tariffs. Uh the McKinley tariffs were
taking place and uh you know massive
amounts of tariffs and now that's being
brought back.
>> You had immigration as well.
>> Yeah, the immigration crisis that was
another thing that was big. You had the
National Reform Association, the NRA.
Now we've got the new apostolic
reformation or the NR
>> and we've got the gilded age where there
was a lot of talk about big business and
um you know massive amounts of uh
control by in the private sector in
influencing the government and now we've
got discussions about the guilded age in
our time period with now a a gilded
presidential ballroom being built. There
are so many similarities between what
was going on in 1888
and what's going on today.
>> Well, you also had the industrial
revolution then and now you have the AI
revolution that is going forward now.
So, we see all these these similarities
between 1888 like you're saying and now.
And it makes me wonder I I think that
the the stream of time we're almost at
the very end of it. But, you know,
you're right. We see these people on
Twitter talking about Sunday, pushing
it, and not not all of them are
Catholic. In fact, most of them are not
Catholic. But we know that there's going
to be a three-fold union of apostate,
Protestant, Protest, Protestantism,
Catholicism, and spiritualism. And the
thing that I look at is we look at
Revelation where we see the first beast
in Revelation 13, and then there's this
second beast that makes an image to the
first beast. You know, we're we're
sitting here talking about sun symbolism
and talking about paganism that's in the
Vatican, which is steeped in it. I mean,
you can look in the in the Vatican where
they have an Egyptian obelisk that was
originally dedicated to the sun god,
which they had brought over at great
expense and great effort was brought to
uh, you know, to bring this over uh from
Egypt and then it was set up there and
is actually the world's largest sun dial
right outside of the main church there
in the Vatican. And you even have the
actual building itself where you have
this this dome that is, you know, right
there at St. Peter's Square where you
have this this arched dome which is
actually what was used for um it's kind
of like a solar temple because you'd
have all this light that came in from
the sun up above. And and indeed, if you
look at the ceiling of St. Peter's
Basilica, you actually see sunbursts
everywhere all around it. You can see
that title Pontifex inscribed or or
pontiff in inscribed right on the
ceiling with all these suns around it.
You even have the high altar, which is
where the pope, you know, celebrates the
mass. And you look behind him and it's
just this giant sunburst. So, we see
this sun symbolism everywhere. And like
you you guys were saying, when they hold
up the Eucharist, they're literally
holding up a white disc and they hold it
up like this, right? And as they hold it
up, what is that? That's the rising sun.
>> But then if you look at uh the
symbolism, how does this second beast
power in Revelation 13 make an image to
the first beast? Well, look at the way
Washington DC is laid out. You actually
have the Capitol building, which is
extremely reminiscent of St. Peter's
Basilica. And you also have a a giant
obelisk. In fact, an even bigger obelisk
with the Washington Monument. And where
does all of this face? Where is Lincoln
when he's sitting in the temple where he
sits, right? Because he sits in a
temple. It says in this temple. It'll
actually say that on the plaqueards and
and and uh engraved behind his head. It
uses the word temple. Okay. Where is he
facing? He's facing east towards a solar
obelisk
towards the capital building. Professor
Vice, I'm sure that you have uh some
commentary there about the various
symbolism that we see where we see this
mimic of Rome here in this second beast
power.
>> Well, it is claimed that the one that is
outside St. John's later, that obelisk
is the obelisk of Dut Moses III.
Now according to William Sheay and
others the that uh particular pharaoh
was the pharaoh of the exodus
and if that is so then that is the one
that said uh who is Yave that I should
obey his voice I do not know him and I
will not obey his voice and that is
exactly reminiscent of what the papacy
is doing.
When they brought that obelisk cross to
Rome, it lay there for many a year
because the papacy made a decree that uh
whoever erected it at great expense. Of
course, if they failed and it broke,
then they would be uh paying for it with
their lives. So, nobody wanted to
attempt it until somebody finally did
and succeeded in in erecting it. And uh
so these are all very interesting facts.
Why would they bring these obelisks
dedicated to the sun god? Because it is
a phallic symbol, but they were also
dedicated to the various pharaohs. Why
would they bring that over and erect it
outside of their main church? Since John
Laner ecclesia, the mother of all the
churches, they even use that title.
It's just so amazing. And then uh as you
say, Sunday, the authority of Sunday
rests solely upon Catholic principles.
There are numerous quotes where Rome
says that the worship of on Sunday is
based on their precepts and theirs
alone. They alone take credit for it.
And if therefore that someone calls for
worship on Sunday, it's actually a call
to accept papal authority in terms of
the moral essence of your life. Well, I
prefer to accept the moral essence of
the this book where God tells us what
the moral essence is and he says that we
should remember the Sabbath day and not
forget it.
So it is a a question of two authorities
in juxiposition.
It's the question of the mark of God
versus the mark of the beast
and it's a question of authority. Who
has the right to rule over my moral
capacity? Is it the papacy or is it God
through his word? And as for me in my
house, I believe that it is God and his
word that dictates moral authority and
not some earthly usurper.
>> It's interesting that you mentioned that
obelisk because that would that would
have been the Pharaoh that forbade a
Sabbath rest.
>> Yes, I just wanted to say that. It's
exactly the same. You let the people
Shabbat,
>> you make them rest, Moses. You make them
keep the Sabbath. Get you to your
burdens. That's an anti-Sabbath law. Do
you know if you take that back
uh the council of Nissa already started
talking about uh you know these things
but it's the council of Laa eventually
which made the decree that uh you were
not allowed to keep the Sabbath. That's
exactly what Pharaoh did. He said you
Moses you make the people Shabbat get
you to your burdens. I'm telling you you
will not rest.
Only the Catholic Church has ever made
such a law and and relies on it to this
very day. It is a blasphemy beyond
blasphemies. And that people don't see
it is because they have hidden it under
such a pile of of paganistic rituals
that uh you can't see you can't see the
light for all the the paraphernalia
that's placed in front of it. But you
guys just mentioned earlier that um
James and and Alex about how similar we
have the period now to 1888
and
I believe that this time what happened
in Pharaoh's time when that law got
through the plagues fell.
>> The plagues fell. Yes. So in 1888 it was
just swept away because it's like the
first siege if you take the siege of
Jerusalem. So I don't think we're going
to see it getting pushed aside again in
the second siege.
>> I believe we're in the process of the
second siege. And as they all claim, it
must be a synchronized day of worship.
So it can't be any day.
And uh the only day that is left after
all the labor legislation is the Sunday.
And as Ramon Novaram said that this is
the day which the state must guarantee.
And so a modern pope Leo who made it his
business to emphatically state that he
is involved with uh implementing rum
Novarum.
Well, that's the main point of rarum
novarum that all labor legislation has
to be centered around papal moral issues
of which Sunday is the core because it
determines by whose authority you
actually act. You know, one thing that I
think is important is that we as 7th day
Adventists have, you know, inscribed in
our logo, we have the three angels
message. This has been our message to
the world, right? We've said this is our
message. Revelation 14 starting in verse
six going forward. That's our message to
the world.
>> But you know sometimes people will ask
us you know why are you just sitting
here focusing on the papacy? Why are you
sitting here you know just just that's
the only thing you'll talk about?
>> But it's because of those messages.
>> Exactly.
>> If you read those messages two out of
the three are warning about a false
system of worship and warning about
receiving a mark.
>> Yes. So if if we're truly preaching this
message, if if you're not hearing this
discussed from the pulpit, are you
really hearing the three angels message?
The gospel goes forth first and then
it's those two things.
>> Yeah. And if you only hear law, law,
law, Sunday, Sabbath, Sunday, Sabbath,
then you you're really missing the point
>> because we're looking at two systems of
salvation here. We're looking at the
pagan system of salvation by works where
you pay for your own sins as the papacy
claims you do in purgatory. You have to
pay for your own sins because they deny
the atonement
or righteousness by faith in verity.
Does righteousness by faith negate
keeping the law? No. Paul implicitly
said, "Do we therefore abrogate the law?
God forbid we uphold the law. It's
because you are saved through
righteousness by faith that you come
back into harmony with with the law.
Whereas the papal system, it is through
obedience that you come back into
harmony with the system. So there are
two diametrically opposed ways of of
seeing salvation. The one is centered in
Christ as the atoning sacrifice. Rome
denies the atonement as purgatory
proves. They claim it publicly. They
state it openly. And therefore, it is
not a Christian religion but a pagan
form of Christianity.
And also if you continually show the
people what Rome was, has been, and
still is, they can understand. And then
you show them the tentacles where it's
leading into. It's not just a a um a
church organization. It's got its
tentacles in everything. Then that's why
it's being spoken of the whole time. And
the Bible doesn't warn about all the
other things. It it warns about this
system.
Let's take let's take uh the modern
papacy. We've had the e economic uh
super supermen all visiting the papacy.
We've had the sports fraternity visiting
the papacy. The present pope just had
the Hollywood crowd visiting the papacy.
Heads of state and governments visit the
papacy. Churches and religious systems
worship or come to the papacy. All of
them, all of them are basically
integrated into this super harlot system
with uh the inscription Babylon, the
mother of harlots and that is a very
inclusive uh term mother of harlots
because there are plenty of them. It in
includes the churches, right?
>> Unfortunately.
>> Yes. So there you have the whole the
whole plethora. There's no other system
in the world that qualifies such as the
papacy does for all the directives that
we have in in the Bible.
>> You know, uh, Ellen White said here in
Review and Herald in 1908, she said,
"The forces of evil are gathering in
strength. Satan flatters his co-workers
that he will do a work that will
captivate the world. While partial
inactivity has come upon the church,
Satan and his hosts are intensely
active."
>> Yeah. So you think about um the the pope
recently met with all the Jesuits and he
basically gave them a commission that
they were to go forth and they were
needed. Now the Jesuits were a direct
response. They were the
counterreformation. They were a response
to the reformation at the time. So by
saying that to the Jesuits and I do not
believe that their directive has
changed. They are still the direct
counterreformation.
So when he meets with him and says I
need you
when he beca when he be came into office
within one month he was talking about
uniting the east and the west.
>> Now he is going and meeting with the
east and discussing you know with uh
Bartholomew discussing with uh with with
these sides trying to get them to unite
pushing forward this ecumenical
approach. If you watch, he's not wasting
any time. He's going forward with great
intensity.
>> And he specifically said that he wants
to have the Eastern Orthodox churches
change the day on which they keep Easter
because Easter Sunday is to them the the
the center that led to the weekly
Sunday.
uh every Sunday is a mini Easter
according to uh the papacy and of course
that word Easter comes from the goddess
Ishta. So this papacy is is busy doing
that and just take the symbolism of all
the u the games that are being portrayed
whether they are in in sports arenas or
whether they are in the Olympics. So all
of these all of these indicators are
showing the very deep pagan roots that
you find in all of these organizations
and systems in the world.
>> But you've also got uh the you mentioned
now the the Bartholomew and the Orthodox
and all of them. But you've had um King
Charles also who has gone right and got
a seat inside of the Vatican. the first
time in 500 years that anything like
that happened as well.
>> That that's a powerful symbol that
Protestantism has totally capitulated.
>> You look at the way this is wrapping up
and you see the intense activity that is
going forward. You see this ecumenism
that is going forward and it should make
us realize that we're right here at the
absolute close of this world's history.
There's 8 billion people alive on this
planet and soon this will be a desolate
wasteland in just a few short years. We
don't know the exact time but it is
coming with great rapidity. And so this
three angels message that we have to
give two out of the three warnings the
last two warnings are about Babylon and
this mark. But you know that first angel
goes forth with the everlasting gospel
to preach to them that dwell on the
earth. So the thing is is we shouldn't
start this whole thing by saying, "Oh,
there's going to be this fearful time
coming. We're not going to be able to
buy and sell." And just end with fear.
>> And that's one thing that we've actually
tried to do with our ministry. We are
heritage and hope. So we're trying to
add hope in there. And we're trying to
say, listen, lift up your heads for your
redemption draws nigh. So what is this
this message of hope that we have? You
know, we just discussed these parallels
between 1888 and now.
One of the other things that was going
forward in 1888 was a message of
righteousness by faith.
>> We cannot do anything to merit our own
our own uh salvation. Our righteousness
is as filthy rags.
>> But if we read the council given in
revelation chapter 3 to the seven
churches and we know that we are in
Leodysia, we need the gold that is tried
in the fire, the eye salv that we might
see. We need the robe of Christ's
righteousness that is put on us. And so
that message of righteousness by faith,
leaving off sin, believing that Christ
can do something for ourselves that we
cannot do. He can provide supernatural
help so that we may overcome sin.
>> That's the message that has to go
forward in addition to these other two.
>> Amen.
>> There's a parallel there.
If you go to creation,
uh what did we contribute to creation?
Absolutely nothing. Right? We were the
last product of that creative act, the
creation of humanity at the end of the
sixth day basically.
So we had no input in creation and
therefore we had to rest according to
the Sabbath commandment in the completed
works of Christ. Now the exact same
thing applies to the recreation which is
the atonement.
So therefore you have a second in
Deuteronomy chapter 5 you have a second
list of ten commandments where it says
remember that you were slaves in Egypt
and the Lord took you out there with an
outstretched arm. So in other words, he
takes you out of the slavery of sin. And
just as we had no contribution in the
creation because we were not even there,
we have no contribution that we can
bring through our works in the
recreation of our fallen nature. That is
something that Christ has to do. And uh
until this vile body is changed into his
glorious body, the only claim to
righteousness that I have is his
spotless robe of righteousness which he
imputes to me or to those that believe
on his name. So the very essence of the
Sabbath is remember that you had nothing
to do with creation and that you have no
power to implement a recreation.
Therefore, everything that you do rests
on the righteousness of Christ and his
creative and recreative power. And the
papacy says, "No,
you have something that you can do and
you pay for your own sins and you
rectify your ways and basically you do
not need this righteousness by faith."
So the Sabbath issue is not just a
question of a day. It's a question of
resting in the completed work that
Christ has done or resting on papal
mandates and decrees. Which one of the
two is going to bring you to through the
ply gates? Well, I think this is the
message that we have to give to the
world and it's not one where we are
trying to um tell people that all
Catholics are somehow evil
>> or you know that we're we're somehow
staunchly anti-atholic and we can't
stand Catholics. That's not the the case
at all. I long for their salvation. And
I believe that many well-meaning
Catholics out there, Christ will examine
their character. And I I believe that
many will be in heaven because they did
not they were not told the truth, but
they lived up to the light that they
had. Um rather my contention is with the
system of worship uh that is is being
pushed. And this is not a a thing that
is isolated to Adventism, but this is
actually all of Protestantism believed
this notion. Um let's go ahead and uh
close with a brief word of prayer. Um
and we'll go from there. Our dear father
in heaven
[music]